All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week, David. Shouldn't Joe Biden be
bragging about the stock market the way Trump
did? I don't mean because Joe Biden is actually
responsible for the stock market, but because
Trump seemed to do well when he bragged about it.
I like the way that this question is asked because
it's not being asked as a question of whether Joe
Biden deserves credit. I mean, as we've talked
about before, to some degree, the sort of economic
circumstances over which a president has
some influence impact the stock market.
But the stock market performance alone is often
used kind of as a political football. And Donald
Trump certainly regularly would talk about how
great the stock market is doing when it was up,
not when it was down and many of his followers
fell for it. It's really a question of whether
politically it would be advantageous for Joe Biden
to do it. I think that it's not clear that it
would because Joe Biden's base is so different
than Donald Trump's base. Donald Trump's base
was disproportionately made up of people who were
never involved in politics before or who were, and
they fell for Republican nonsense. So they were
like the perfect marks for just hearing from Trump
about the stock market. And the Joe Biden base is
different. And it doesn't strike me as something
that would be so obviously beneficial for Joe
Biden to brag about the stock market in the
same way that Donald Trump did. Now, that being
said, just because you don't have the sort of
sycophantic cult of personality cheerleaders on
the left that you had on the right around Donald
Trump doesn't mean Joe Biden shouldn't talk about
the stock market in the context of talking about
how we're doing. So certainly Joe Biden should be
saying we're vaccinating more than three million
a day. Covid deaths are down 77 percent. Cases are
down roughly the same percentage. Unemployment is
down. We are seeing job creation. Stock market
is at record highs on and. So it's a package
overall. But if the question is, should Joe Biden
start tweeting about the stock market from a golf
course, the way, you know, the caricature of
what Donald Trump was doing, I don't think it's
it's what Joe Biden should be doing. One other
aspect to why it's important for Biden to talk
about the stock market numbers is that you
do want to try at least to get the media to
put out messages that are advantageous to
you. Any president would try to do this. And
rather than just leaving it to corporate media
to figure out, oh, the stock market is doing
well. And Joe Biden's president and we were told
that it was going to be a disaster by Trump if
Joe Biden were president, why not? Again,
this is sort of like communications and PR
feed the story to the media in, in some
sense, what one other aspect of this.
When Donald Trump insisted during the campaign
that if Joe Biden wins, your 401. KS will be worth
nothing, the economy will collapse, unemployment
will explode, covid death will explode, suicides
will explode, you won't have windows in buildings,
you won't have indoor heating, you won't have
indoor cooling. You'll have to flush the toilet
10 to 15 times. You'll have to run your dishwasher
two or three times to get your dishes cleaned. We
knew all that stuff was crazy, but in particular
now Joe Biden talking about what the stock market
is doing might be a good way to get media outlets
to put more Republicans on the spot and say you
agreed with Trump during the campaign that if Joe
Biden were president, this would happen to the
market. The markets are at record highs. What
say you? They would almost certainly retreat to
something like, well, Joe Biden has inflated the
stock market by, quote, printing money through
stimulus. And he wants to do infrastructure,
but they'll be on the ropes and they will have a
defense. It'll be a really stupid defense. So the
position Joe Biden should take is take credit
for turning things around and talk about the
stock market as one of many indicators as
to how things are continuing to improve.